[Musique]
olympie ce prestigieux sanctuaire de
l'antiquité grecque est connu dans le
monde entier pour être le berceau des
jeux olympiques pendant près de milan
des épreuves sportives ont rassemblé ici
les citoyens de la grèce antique
des athlètes ont ébloui le stade de
leurs exploits sous les ovations de la
foule chacun tentait de dépasser ses
limites
pour faire honneur aux dieux mais avec
l'interdiction des olympiades le site
dévasté emporte ses secrets
grâce au travail des archéologues une
grande partie du sanctuaire a pu être
mis au jour les nouvelles technologies
permettent aujourd'hui de représenter
cette époque de manière réaliste il est
désormais possible de redonner vie aux
merveilles disparu d'olympie comme la
statue de zeus
le matin quand les portes du temple
était ouverte
les rayons du soleil entraient et
éclairer la statue des spécialistes des
sports antiques tente de décrypter les
techniques des compétitions pour la
première fois une caméra capable de
filmer à très haute vitesse nous révèle
les gestes des athlètes du passé les
grecs ne cherche pas à courir plus vite
possible
il cherche à gagner l'épreuve dans
l'antiquité c'est juste la victoire qui
compte
de vastes espaces de l'impie reste
encore ensevelies comme par exemple
l'hippodrome comment se déroulaient les
courses de chars
épreuve reine où s'affrontaient des
attelages aussi puissant que dangereux
de nos jours le monde continue à se
passionner pour les compétitions
sportives retrouvons la mémoire des
premiers jeux olympiques
d'après les récits antiques nous sont
parvenus l'histoire de la grèce a
toujours été ponctuée par d'incessants
conflits
pendant des siècles les cités comme
athènes ou sparte s'affrontent pour
contrôler et de nouveaux territoires
alors
à
dès leur plus jeune âge les grecs sont
préparés pour défendre leur cité pour
cela ils sont soumis à de rudes
entraînement pour devenir soldat
[Applaudissements]
pourtant une coutume veut que
régulièrement les armées cesse de
combattre le temps d'une trêve pour
rendre hommage au dieu
les citoyens sont appelés à cesser de se
battre pour le pouvoir
ils peuvent juste s'affronter pour la
gloire
c'est l'origine des sports antiques des
compétitions où se mêlent des pratiques
guerrière et des racines plus lointaines
les premiers spectacles sportifs
apparaissent il y a trois mille cinq
cents ans en crète minoenne dans les
palais deux jeunes gens se mesure à des
taureaux dans de périlleux sow l'ancêtre
de la boxe est aussi présent à la même
période
ces épreuves organisées en public m'ont
influencé les grecs qui au fil des
siècles inventeront de nouveaux sports
plusieurs sites y organise des
rencontres sportives pour célébrer leur
dieu comme à athènes où les jeux ont
lieu en l'honneur de la déesse athéna ou
encore à delphes pour honorer apollon
mais les jeux les plus prestigieux de
l'histoire sont ceux d'olympie toutes
les cités du monde grec qui participent
sous l'égide du plus grand des dieux
zeus tous les quatre ans
des messages et parcourt le monde grec
pour annoncer une nouvelle très attendue
la date des jeux olympiques
[Musique]
un mois al avance on déclare une trêve
pour que tout le monde puisse venir
assister aux jeux pour que les sportifs
qui sont des citoyens de toutes les
cités du monde grec puisse venir
s'entraîner
par terre et par mer des athlètes venus
de tout le bassin méditerranéen
convergent vers l'ouest du péloponnèse
la péninsule au sud de la grèce
continentale
ces routes qui traversent les collines
et les rivières ont été empruntés par de
nombreuses générations d'athlètes et de
supporters tous sont impatients
d'arriver au bout du voyage et de
découvrir enfin le stade d'olympie pour
participer à l'effervescence de ses jeux
à la croisée des chemins
à deux jours de marche d'olympie des
juges vêtu d'une toge rouge guide la
foule vers le site
non
surplombant la vallée le mont chronos
aux frais comme aujourd'hui une vue
imprenable sur le paysage olympien
[Musique]
un site longé par deux rivières est
plantée d'arbres sacré
[Musique]
à
cette vallée qui a attiré les jeux
pendant toute l'antiquité a été
recouverte par des séries d'inondations
avant de tomber dans l'oubli
plus de mille ans s'écouleront avant que
les archéologues ne la retrouve
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en entrant à olympie les participants
découvrent enfin le sanctuaire dans
toute la splendeur de ses monuments
aujourd'hui il ne reste plus que
quelques ruines du site originel mais
voici à quoi ressemblait olympie à son
apogée
à l'ouest les bâtiments dédiés à
l'entraînement des athlètes
à l'est le stade et l'hippodrome
attendent la tenue des jeux
[Musique]
au centre la partie sacrée et ses
temples ses allées ont été découvertes
par plusieurs générations d'archéologues
le premier d'entre eux est l'anglais
richard chandler en 1766 ils localisent
le site d'olympie en recoupant des
récits antiques comme celui de
l'historien pausanias
[Musique]
quatre décennies plus tard les français
sont les premiers à entamer les fouilles
[Musique]
en 1828
la france s'engage dans la guerre
d'indépendance grecque et cette
expédition n'a pas qu'un but militaire
il se trouve que la france décide de
coupler cette expédition militaire avec
une expédition scientifique en
l'occurrence ce sont des botanistes des
zoologues des géologues mais aussi des
architectes des archéologues des
spécialistes de sculptures qui arrive en
grèce
en 1829 et une partie des équipes
travaillent notamment sur le site de
nantes 7 premières fouilles ne porte que
sur une infime partie du site
mais les français vont découvrir des
restes d'un temple massif
ils sont persuadés qu'il s'agit de celui
de zeus
[Musique]
ce qui confirme la découverte du coeur
de l'api
[Musique]
à partir de 1875 les fouilles sont
reprises par l'allemagne
les archéologues vont dégager la plupart
des monuments du sanctuaire et les
contours du stade
grâce à ces travaux herculéens le site
d'olympie va progressivement retrouvé la
lumière de nos jours
le site est toujours fouillées par des
archéologues de différentes nationalités
nous avons moins d'ouvriers qu'au début
des fouilles mais nous disposons d'une
main d'oeuvre locale qui est très bien
formés et expérimentés
son travail est encadrée et surveillée
par des chercheurs et des étudiants
en principe nous effectuons les fouilles
de la même manière qu'il y a des
décennies mais avec plus de précision et
de soins quand il s'agit de décaper
documenté et dégager des différentes
couches par petites étapes
les fouilles à olympie n'ont pour le
moment pas révélé de quartiers
d'habitation pour l'hébergement des
nombreux visiteurs antique
les participants devaient probablement
s'installer le long des deux rivières
qui encadraient le site leur eau
permettait de se désaltérer dans la
chaleur de l'été
[Applaudissements]
c'est là quelque part entre les temples
les enclos pour les bêtes et les
bâtiments réservés aux sportifs que
devait se trouver le village olympique
un espace qui rassemblait sans doute des
campement sommaire où l'on dormait à la
belle étoile ou sous une tente pour les
plus fortunés
on ignore le nombre exact de personnes
présentes sans doute plusieurs dizaines
de milliers assister aux jeux olympiques
devaient offrir un spectacle autant pour
les épreuves que pour ce rassemblement
de grecs venus de toute la méditerranée
avec leur accent leur jeu et leur
gastronomie
les sportifs s'entraînent dans plusieurs
lieux comme la palestre un vaste espace
encadré par une colonnade dans
l'antiquité
ces couloirs supporter à une toiture
[Musique]
dans la cour de la palestre les athlètes
doivent faire leurs preuves
les juges les observe s'entraîner et
décide qui parmi eux est suffisamment
vaillant pour avoir l'honneur de
concourir aux jeux
les entraînements sont ouverts au public
qui s'amusent à parier sur les chances
des uns et des autres
[Musique]
les athlètes représentent la cité dont
ils sont originaires mais qui sont ces
sommes autorisés à concourir dans un
sanctuaire aussi prestigieux toutes les
cités du monde grec pouvait participer
pour autant qu'elles soient considérées
comme véritablement grecque c'est-à-dire
nom barbare régis par des institutions
grecques
adorant des dieux grecs et dont les
citoyens parlent et le grec
il devait faire la preuve de leur
citoyenneté il venait donc témoigner en
présence de leurs pères de leurs frères
et de leurs entraîneurs pour dire je
suis bien citoyen d'athènes je suis bien
citoyen de corinthe ou deux parties afin
de présenter et d'inscrire
officiellement leur champion les
délégations se rendent au boulot
thériault sièges du sénat olympique
il est situé à côté de l'enceinte sacrée
[Applaudissements]
devant les juges les athètes prête le
serment d'olympie ils s'engagent à
respecter les règles et à ne pas tricher
[Applaudissements]
dès l'ouverture des jeux les spectateurs
se pressent en masse pour assister aux
épreuves dans un vaste espace public le
stade
plus célèbres sites sportifs du monde
antique le stade d'olympie se présente
aujourd'hui à peu près dans sa forme
ancienne
il est pourtant restée ensevelie pendant
plus de quinze siècles dans les années
l'allemagne décide de tout mettre en
oeuvre pour révéler les installations
sportives d'olympie à l'aide d'un réseau
ferré des centaines de tonnes de terre
sont déblayés et les 192 mètres du stade
émerge des sédiments
c'est par ce long couloir voûtée en
pierres que les athlètes entre dans le
stade sous les acclamations de la foule
les spectateurs sont rassemblés sur les
talus qui entourent le stade une des
révélations des fouilles confirme
l'austérité du site en dehors d'une
terrasse pour les juges le stade ne
comporte aucun gradins les spectateurs
devaient donc se serrer sur le simple
monticule d'herbe et de terre
le public est essentiellement masculin
dans de rares cas seuls les jeunes
filles non mariées ont le droit
d'accéder à olympie desmyter la déesse
de la fertilité est représenté au stade
par sa prêtresse les athlètes se
positionne sur cette ligne de départ en
marre
la première course est une épreuve
d'endurance au signal de coureurs
s'élancent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils vont parcourir une distance de 24
stade soit environ 4500 m
un grand nombre de poterie pinte ont été
retrouvés sur le site d'olympie on y
voit avec précision les athlètes
pratiquer leur sport
des témoignages précieux pour les
historiens
une des spécificités de la céramique
grec s'est effectivement d'être une
céramique peinte et les scènes peintes
sont d'une richesse exceptionnelle on a
parfois parlé de la seranne y comme d'un
grand livre d'image et ses images 1
contrairement à aujourd'hui on n'allait
pas dans les musées pour les voir mais
elle faisait partie du quotidien des
grecs
on les retrouve dans tous les contextes
de la vie quotidienne dans l'habitat
c'est effectivement des objets usuels
mais aussi dans les sanctuaires c'était
des offrandes aux dieux et enfin elle
accompagne aussi le mort dans la tombe
aussi riche soit elle ses peintures dont
révèle-t-elle toute la réalité sur les
sports pratiqués à olympie à ya quelque
chose effectivement de très concret de
très chatoyant dans la céramique grecque
qui suscite cette tentation d'une
lecture spontanée et immédiate de
l'image mais ce serait un grave
contresens d'assimiler donc le peintre
de vase
un reporter à un photographe croquant
sur le vif une scène vue à olympie ces
images même si elles sont effectivement
très naturel sont souvent des images
construites codifié et qu'il faut
décoder
décodé l'image c'est ce que fait
l'archéologie expérimentale une
discipline qui tests en conditions
réelles les gestes des sportifs du passé
[Musique]
dans le sud de la france dès sportifs
féru d'histoire s'entraîne depuis des
années à reproduire les épreuves
quantique
un travail qui permet de mieux
comprendre les pratiques sportives de
l'époque
on a des centaines et des centaines
d'image d'athlètes et on va pouvoir par
tests successifs retrouver les gestes
les plus probables
aujourd'hui les nouvelles avancées
technologiques nous offre la possibilité
d'en savoir plus une nouvelle caméra
numérique capable d'enregistrer
plusieurs milliers d' images par seconde
permet pour la première fois de
décomposer les gestes des sportifs les
images 1,38 vitesse nous apprennent
plein de choses
quant aux détails techniques à la
décomposition du mouvement on nous
montre à un moment donné l'image du val
tels que l'artiste la paix ya plus de
2000 ans
[Musique]
après l'endurance l'épreuve de vitesse
bien que presque deux fois plus longue
c'est l'ancêtre de notre célèbre
épreuves du 100 m quelles pouvaient être
les performances des sportifs de
l'époque alors qu'il courait pieds nus
les grecs ne cherche pas à courir le
plus vite possible
il cherche à gagner l'épreuve il faut
pas imaginer ça comme une course record
nous aujourd'hui on est dans la course à
la performance aux records tandis que
dans l'antiquité c'est juste la victoire
qui compte donc on peut gagner en
mettant un terme très très longue c'est
très difficile et même impossible
d'imaginer une comparaison certaines
épreuves sont inspirés de pratiques
guerrière comme la course en armes
tous les athlètes doivent contourner un
piqué le même piqué pour tout le monde
sans le toucher sinon on est disqualifié
et donc il faut savoir se positionner
dans ce peloton qui est formé juste
avant le contournement du piquet on peut
prendre appui sur les adversaires pour
mieux freiner mieux contourner et
entamer la dernière ligne droite
c'est très intéressant de voir sur les
vases grecs justement ces athlètes qui
courent et qui tendent le bras pour
justement empêcher l'autre ne passait
s'appuyer sur lui si a besoin après les
efforts de la journée
les athlètes se rendent tous terne
clients les pièces latéral de la
palestre of les athlètes pouvaient
changer de vêtements et mais également
se laver dans ces petits bassins ou
vache
pour les sportifs c'est un moment de
détente les hommes enlèvent la poussière
et la sueur de leur corps
nous avons ici une stèle tombales en
marbre elle représente un sportif en
train de se rappeler la peau avec un
stryges il cet objet est destinée
principalement à l'athlète pour qu'ils
puissent nettoyer son corps en faisant
ce geste
après s'être racler la peau les sportifs
s'enduisent le corps du nil qui agit
comme un vernis protecteur
la plupart du temps les athlètes sont
représentés nu sur les sculptures ou les
poteries
mais dans les faits les compétiteurs
s'affrontent et ils tous complètement nu
lors des premiers siècles des concours
on sait que les athlètes retroussé
notamment leur tunique
on apprend que par la suite la plupart
d'entre eux concours revenus pour les
épreuves du pentathlon notamment la
course ou encore pour certaines
compétitions de lutte
mais pour les sportifs de l'archéologie
expérimentale cette nudité est loin
d'être évidente
dans la pratique c'est beaucoup trop
dangereux de par exemple courir nu pour
les parties génitales ça représente un
danger il est certain qu'ils
connaissaient ce danger pour nous ces
athlètes ont représenté nu sur les
documents archéologiques est une
convention artistique c'est à dire que
c'est le choix de l'artiste de les
représenter dans leur beauté maximum
[Musique]
une oeuvre majeure de l'antiquité
illustre l'intention des artistes grecs
d'idéaliser le corps de l'athlète
[Musique]
attribué à mme hyron le discobole est à
l'origine un bronze copier en pierre par
les romains il représente un lanceur de
disque lui aussi dans le plus simple
appareil
[Musique]
le discobole de miron représente le
moment où l'athlète s'apprête à lancer
le disque c'est une vision abstraite du
lancer du disque justement ça n'est pas
la réalité
ces cercles observations de la
musculature dans ses moindres détails
mais tout est compris dans un schéma
géométriques la ligne de tel ou tel
muscles se répondent et par ailleurs
l'ensemble de la composition est un jeu
de triangle isocèle ou rectangle emboîté
autrement dit c'est la vision idéale du
lancer du disque et non pas la réalité
du lancer du disque mais pour mme hyron
l'auteur de cette statue l'essentiel
était de montrer de façon convaincante
et harmonieuse
le lancer du disque
le disque aurait lui aussi une origine
militaire lancée dans une bataille il
pouvait stopper l'élan des troupes en
retombant sur les adversaires et en leur
prise en les eaux parmi les objets du
musée
nous avons ici un disque en bronze cet
exemplaire est grave et on connaît le
donateur il appartenait à pau quilles
hausse à skis pièce il a été trouvé ici
à olympique où l'on a découvert
plusieurs disques de différentes tailles
certains servait pour les épreuves des
jeux d'autres étaient utilisés comme des
offrandes aux dieux comme l'attestent
son inscription
il date de 241 après jésus-christ
ces disques pouvait atteindre 30 cm de
diamètre et peser jusqu'à 6 kg il
fallait beaucoup de force et de
dextérité pour lancer cette forme aussi
loin que possible lors de leur test les
sportifs de l'archéologie expérimentale
n'ont jamais dépassé 15 à 20 mètres
selon le poids des écrits antique
raconte que les grecs anciens parvenait
à réaliser des lancers de 24 m
[Musique]
pour atteindre un tel niveau de
performance les sportifs antique avait
parfois recours à quelques astuces
quand il lançait le javelot les grecques
cédait de cette petite ficelle un
propulseur et on va utiliser un
propulseur qui va servir donc à lancer
effectivement plus loin parce qu'on aura
un levier supplémentaire mais aussi avec
plus de précision le propulseur va
obliger le javelot à tourner sur
lui-même et cette rotation va donner une
meilleure percée dans l'air et donc une
trajectoire beaucoup plus rectiligne
malgré le jean
autre avantage du propulseur il permet
d'éviter que le javelot ne dévie sur la
foule amassée autour du stade
[Musique]
les archéologues grecs continuent
aujourd'hui de fouiller un espace encore
méconnu
le gymnase construit au 2e siècle avant
notre ère ce lieu d'entraînement était
bien plus vaste que la palestre
le but de cette fouille qui est pratiqué
par le service archéologique grecque est
de mettre au jour de nouvelles portions
des colonnades elle doit révéler la
taille de cette installation est mieux
la présenter aux visiteurs
et puis s'ils se faisait l'entraînement
de plusieurs disciplines où les athlètes
avaient besoin de distance et d'élans
comme la course à pied ou encore le
javelot dans le gymnase
on s'entraîne également pour l'épreuve
du saut en longueur mais le saut tel
qu'il était pratiqué dans l'antiquité
était bien différent du sort aujourd'hui
les sauteurs utiliser des poids qui leur
permettait de se propulser beaucoup plus
loin il a fallu faire pas mal
d'expérience pour comprendre
l'utilisation de ses poids et ce qui
vient très vite à l'esprit c'est un
système de balancier en fait il est
logique d'utiliser ses haltères pour se
donner de l'inertie vers l'avant et il
faut arriver à coordonner les bras et
les jambes pour sauter toujours avec le
maximum de d'inertie vers l'avant c'est
ça rend la discipline encore plus
technique et plus éprouvantes aussi
physiquement
la plus haute performance retrouver et
de 16 mètres 50
c'est ce qui nous a fait penser que il
devait faire cinq sauts moins de cinq
sauts 16 mètres 50 c'est tout simplement
pas possible à atteindre 5 saussez ce
qui a de plus cohérent et pour avoir
pratiqué longuement
je me suis entraîné beaucoup pour
arriver à approcher les performances de
l'antiquité
j'ai un record personnel à environ de 17
[Applaudissements]
tout au long des jeux la mythologie est
omniprésente
le soir venu les anciens racontent
l'origine d'olympie où les légendes
l'emportent sur la réalité
l'une d'entre elles évoquent pélops l'un
des héros de la mythologie grecque
le demi dieu aurait conquis olympique en
remportant une course de chars contre
son ennemi le roi hinault maus pour
honorer les dieux dont il estimait avoir
obtenu la protection vélhop serait créé
les premiers jeux olympiques
d'autres légende attribue l'origine
d'olympie un héros grecs bien connu
d'après d'autres mythes se serait recul
qui aurait fondé les jeux olympiques
lors de son passage dans la région de
l'est lead où nous nous trouvons il
avait accompli l'un de ces travaux
nettoyer les écuries d'augias et
à olympie les athlètes et les
spectateurs multiplient les hommages aux
dieux l'exploration des couches
archéologiques nous révèle l'importance
de ces pratiques
les archéologues allemands mettent
régulièrement au jour des dépôts
d'objets métalliques qui sont la plupart
du temps très détériorée
[Musique]
voilà suite à notre dernière fouille
nous venons de retrouver cette très
longue lens
m
il
dans le sens qui redonne un pion la
découverte des armes mais enfouie
notamment dans le secteur du stade
en fait il était de coutume pour les
grecs d'offrir le casque de leurs
adversaires at the cards off et la
divinité qui préside à la compétition ou
à l'affrontement militaire
ce ne sont pas seulement des armes qui
ont été découvertes dans le sol mais
aussi d'innombrables ex voto ces
figurines était offerte aux dieux pour
leur demander protection chance ou
guérison
[Musique]
quand on gagne on va vouloir remercier
les deux d'avoir joué en notre faveur
pour obtenir la victoire
vador ou que leur offrir des statuts des
disques c'est vraiment pour remercier
les dieux d'avoir fait pencher la
victoire en notre faveur
[Musique]
les poteries et les écrits des auteurs
antiques évoque aussi de grands
sacrifices d'animaux lors de la période
des jeux
le nom du plus important et du plus
spectaculaire d'entre eux est resté dans
le langage commun pour désigner un
massacre de grande ampleur une hécatombe
lors d'une longue cérémonie sans besson
sacrifié en l'honneur de zeus
[Musique]
vous
à olympie le plus grand des hôtels de
sacrifices format monticule constitué
des cendres de centaines d'animaux
accumulés au fil du temps seule une
partie de la viande était offerte aux
dieux
le reste était distribué pour nourrir
les participants
les sports de combat sont l'une des
attractions emblématique des jeux la
lutte oppose deux athlètes tirés au sort
les hommes ne se découvrent qu'au
dernier moment
les règles sont très proches de la lutte
actuelle celui qui réussit à envoyer son
adversaire au sol trois fois
consécutives remporte l'épreuve
[Musique]
ancêtre de la boxe le pugilat et depuis
longtemps pratiqué dans l'antiquité le
pugilat se pratiquer avec des bandages
sur les mains c'était fait pour protéger
les métacarpe des boxeurs évidemment ça
renforcer aussi leurs poèmes et donc
leurs coûts et l'impact sur l'intérêt
très violent les coûts ne se donnent pas
la tête
les combats peuvent durer très longtemps
il en va de l'honneur des athlètes
on sait que c'est un sport violent et
pour lequel il pouvait y avoir
éventuellement des blessures très graves
et pourquoi pas des décès mais il n'y a
pas d'objectif de tuer l'autre on doit
le mettre ko ou s'abandonner
à bout de forces les plus faibles
doivent demander l'interruption du
combat ou risquer de le terminer par
leur propre mort
quand on lit pausanias qui écrit au
deuxième siècle de notre ère on sait
l'histoire de tel ou tel grands
pugilistes on sait la violence de
certaines épreuves
il ya par exemple comment tel athlète a
pu littéralement mangé toutes ses dents
à la fin d'un combat de puijila pour ne
pas perdre la face
[Musique]
ce bronze a l'apparence d'un masque nous
les montre le visage d'un pugiliste
marquée par les combats
il s'agirait du portrait de satire
hausse plusieurs fois vainqueur à
olympie
parmi les sports de combat le plus
violent et le pancrace on va avoir à la
fois de la percussion à la fin du combat
au sol et on va voir beaucoup plus de
tentatives de finalisation de
l'adversaire avec des étranglements avec
des clés articulaires quasiment tous les
coups sont permis aux pancras
seuls sont interdites les morsures et
l'arrachage des yeux
[Musique]
mais dans la grèce antique comme dans le
monde moderne les tricheurs existe
certains sportifs
même après avoir prêté le serment d'être
exemplaire tente de l'emporter par des
méthodes douteuses
pour preuve ces statue de zeus les
ânesses qui ornaient les allées
d'olympie les athlètes pris en flagrant
délit de triche devait faire ériger à
leurs frais ses sculptures en bronze
aujourd'hui il n'en reste plus que les
socle en pierre
mais elle devait ressembler à ce bronze
retrouvés en mer près du cap art émision
et qui représentent eux sous poséidon
[Musique]
une fois les épreuves du stade terminé
les spectateurs et les athlètes vont
prendre le temps de célébrer les dieux
en attendant les courses sur
l'hippodrome
[Musique]
à deux pas du stade séparés par un mur
le coeur du sanctuaire est bâti autour
d'un bois sacré la tenue des jeux est
intimement lié à des cultes rendu aux
dieux
chacun avait son temple un des tout
premiers construits est celui des rats
déesse de la fécondité
elle est la soeur et les pousses de zeus
à l'origine tout ces colonnes étaient en
bois elles furent progressivement
remplacées par des colonnes de pierre
[Musique]
le
à l'intérieur du temple d'héra se
trouvait l'hôtel sur lequel était placé
les couronnes pour les futurs vainqueurs
des jeux
[Musique]
à quelques mètres de là au coeur du
sanctuaire se dresse l'imposant temple
de dieu
[Musique]
construit au milieu du 5e siècle avant
notre ère on reconnaît son ordre
le style dorique à la forme de ses
colonnes épaisse et surmonté d'un
chapiteau
[Musique]
plusieurs partis des frontons ont été
retrouvés avec leurs sculptures de
divinités comme apollon
où les centaures figure légendaire de
l'histoire d'olympie
surplombant le coeur du sanctuaire une
sculpture de zeus trône au centre d'une
scène magistrale peintes de couleurs
éclatantes
une partie des trésors appartenant au
temple de zeus à olympie se trouve
aujourd'hui en france au musée du louvre
comme les meet up ces fragments de
statues qui décrivent les douze travaux
d'hercule
la méthode d'olympie sont en marbre de
parole elles sont sculptés en très haut
relief
et comme la plupart des sculptures
architecture à la grec de l'époque
classique elle était peinte les fonds
étaient bleues et les personnages
étaient rehaussées de couleurs
d'ailleurs certains détails ne sont que
peint la chevelure d'héraclès qui se
trouve à côté de moi ce n'est simplement
que pinte
[Musique]
le plus grand trésor abrité par le
temple de zeus a aujourd'hui disparu
il faisait partie des sept merveilles du
monde nous sommes ici devant l'entrée
orientale du temple le seul accès à ce
grand bâtiment de culte à l'intérieur se
trouvaient la statue de zeus
le matin quand les portes du temple
était ouverte
les rayons du soleil entraient et
éclairer la statue d'en bas pour
construire ce chef-d'oeuvre les
responsables d'olympie firent appel à
phidias un sculpteur athéniens réputé
pour avoir édifié la statue d'athéna au
parthénon d'athènes
la représentation du plus grand des
dieux nécessitait un vaste atelier
phidias le fit donc construire dans laxe
du temple de zeus
nous sommes dans l'atelier dit de
phidias c'est ici que la grande statue
de zeus fait en or et en ivoire fut
construite et assemblés avant d'être
transféré dans la celle à l'intérieur du
temple
[Musique]
oh
dans son atelier phidias aidé de ses
disciples travail à les matériaux les
plus précieux le corps de la statue de
zeus été couverts d'ivoire et les
vêtements d'or
[Musique]
une fois installé dans le temple la tête
du dieu touché presque le toit d'une
hauteur estimée à 13 m l'oeuvre de
phidias représentait le plus grand des
dieux assis sur un trône
[Musique]
un bassin rempli d'huile servait à
conserver l'humidité intérieure pour
éviter que l'ivoire ne se dessèchent
la statue restera à olympie pendant près
de cinq siècles avant d'être déménagée à
constantinople puis détruite dans un
incendie
la course de chars est l'épreuve reine
des jeux elle attire le plus grand
nombre de spectateurs au fil des siècles
les attelages comportait soit deux
chevaux les bij soit pendant les
périodes les plus fastes des kadrige
avec quatre chevaux de véritables
machines roulantes tout en puissance
dans la grèce antique
le cheval fait l'objet de culte
les riches propriétaires dépensent des
fortunes pour entretenir leurs écuries
véritable marque de prestige les
artistes rivalisent de réalisme pour
représenter la force et la grâce des
chevaux
à olympie se trouvait l'un des plus
grand terrain de course du monde grec
mais il n'est plus visible aujourd'hui
ensevelie sous la nouvelle vallée
d'olympie on suppose que l'hippodrome
s'étendait sur près de 800 mètres entre
le stade et la rivière alphée
mais ses dimensions exactes demeurent
inconnues car le site n'a jamais été
fouillé
pour se faire une idée de ses courses
spectaculaires il faut quitter le
péloponnèse pour rejoindre d'elf sur le
continent niché dans les montagnes
le sanctuaire de delphes avait lui aussi
ces épreuves sportives les jeux pis tic
les compétitions athlétiques se dérouler
dans un stade à flanc de rocher
dans la vallée un vaste hippodrome lui
aussi disparu accueillait des courses de
chars
en fouillant le site des archéologues
français ont découvert en 1896
une statue quasiment intact c'est l'un
des trésors de l'art grec
ce bronze d'un mètre quatre-vingt
représente un aurige un conducteur de
char les ori j'étais les esclaves où les
employés de propriétaires suffisamment
fortunés pour s'offrir un de ces bolides
de course en général des nobles des rois
ou de riches commerçants
ce groupe en bronze représenter le
cocher lors d'un tour d'honneur après la
victoire c'était une composition assez
ambitieuse qui célébraient la victoire
d'un tyran de sicile polizia l'os de gel
à d'autres restes de l'attelage nous
permettent d'imaginer la statue complète
trônant sur un socle de pierre preuve de
la richesse du propriétaire du char le
quadrige de bronze n'était pas seulement
présenté avec 4 mai avec cinq chevaux
loris de delphes est une précieuse
source d'information pour les chercheurs
il leur a permis de concevoir des
répliques de chars de l'époque
ce char est une reconstitution d'un char
grec de l'époque ancienne l'ensemble de
cet attelage permettait à la fois
d'allier vitesse et stabilité
sur l'hippodrome les attelages se
positionne sur des marques de départ
disposés en v
les conducteurs doivent autant se
concentrer sur la maîtrise des chevaux
que sur la tactique de leurs adversaires
[Musique]
la conduite des chars de course était
sportive il faut imaginer le cocher
l'origine de boue sur le char qui devait
maîtriser quatre chevaux avec tous les
changements de vitesse et de direction
[Musique]
les moments les plus dangereux de la
course sont les virages la vitesse les
forces exercées sur l'attelage et la
proximité des concurrents provoque
souvent des accidents spectaculaires
rares sont les attelages qui regagne
intacte l'arrivée
durant la course de kadrige les sharks
parcours 12 tours de piste soit environ
14 km
[Musique]
terminer premiers d'une course de chars
octroie un prestige considérable - pour
l'origine que pour le propriétaire à qui
revient l'essentiel des honneurs et
surtout sa victoire démontre qu'il a la
faveur des dieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pendant plusieurs jours les athlètes se
sont dépensés sans compter
sous les cris de la foule ils se sont
battus pour la gloire et ont porté
l'honneur de leur site et en repoussant
leurs propres limites
à la fin des épreuves ils vont se
présenter dans le sanctuaire pour
connaître le verdict des juges lors de
la cérémonie officielle un porte parole
annonce le nom du vainqueur et de sa
cité à olympie les vainqueurs sont
décorés d'une simple couronne de
feuilles d'olivier
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors que les conflits armés en grèce se
poursuivent les compétitions continuent
d'avoir lieu tous les quatre ans fait
sans précédent dans l'histoire
les jeux olympiques antiques auront été
tenues avec régularité pendant près d'un
millénaire
au fil des siècles le site d'olympie
évolué et voit l'apparition de nouvelles
constructions
lorsque philippe ii de macédoine envahi
la grèce au ivème siècle avant notre ère
il fait ériger ce temple circulaire le
philly peillon qui apporte une évolution
dans l' architecture d'olympie avec ses
colonnes de style ioniques
à la même période apparaît le léonida y
ont bâti est financé par un architecte
cette vaste auberge est destiné à loger
les athlètes et les visiteurs de marque
lorsque les romains envahissent la grèce
au 2e siècle avant notre ère
le nouvel occupant ne remet pas les jeux
en question
bien au contraire ils apprécient le
spectacle de ces épreuves
placée sous une protection divine certes
un empereur romain participe même aux
compétitions
à condition bien sûr de les gagner comme
néron couronné vainqueur de six épreuves
après avoir soudoyé les juges sous l'ère
romaine l'esprit sportif évolué tant les
romains prennent possession d'olympie là
la forme les jeux restent les mêmes mais
c'est l'esprit derrière qui va changer
on va plus combattre pour la gloire mais
pour l'argent on va devenir un athlète
professionnel
donc on va être payé pour pratiquer ces
jeux et c'est en ça que l'esprit
agonistique l'esprit de valeur et de
courage qui était insufflé dans les jeux
par les grecs mettre un peu galvaudée
par les romains parce qu'ils vont
apporter un esprit de compétition et une
hier on va vraiment vouloir jouer pour
de l'argent
les romains aime tellement les jeux
qu'ils reprennent certaines épreuves
dans les cirques de toul en pire combiné
avec des spectacles plus violents comme
les combats de gladiateurs
ces jeux à la romaine sont des
spectacles très prisé par le peuple mais
la progression du christianisme qui ne
reconnaît qu'un seul dieu et rejette
l'idolâtrie va signer la fin des jeux en
393 de notre ère les olympiades jugé
trop païenne sont interdites
quand l'empereur théodose qui est un
empereur chrétiens proclame un édit il
n'interdit pas directement les jeux il
interdit sur tous les cultes païens donc
les sacrifices
or à olympie tout tourne autour du culte
de zeus et de ses sacrifices donc lady
est proclamée en 390 et dans les années
qui suivent
l'interdiction du culte païen entraîne
presque automatiquement l'interdiction
des jeux
avec le déclin de l'empiré romain au
cinquième siècle olympie perd sa
protection et elle est pillée par des
troupes barbare ou destruction des
hommes vont succéder les ravages de la
nature à plusieurs reprises le site
subit des tremblements de terre qui
détruisent les lourdes colonne des
temples
le site d'olympie et peu à peu abandonné
les crues successives des deux rivières
qui contourne le site achève le travail
de dévastation la vallée et enseveli
sous 6 mètres de terre olympique se fera
oublier pendant des siècles
les jeux vont renaître sous l'impulsion
d'un homme pierre de coubertin féru de
sport cet historien veut contribuer à le
rendre populaire en créant une
compétition internationale à la fin du
19e siècle
les archéologues ont déblayé une partie
d'olympie pierre de coubertin décide
alors de reprendre le concept des jeux
antiques les premiers jeux olympiques
modernes voit le jour en 1896 à athènes
12 pays participent à cette première
édition
[Musique]
c'est plus l'esprit général que monsieur
coubertin a voulu je pense transmettre
dans ces nouveaux jeux olympiques le
fais déjà qui porte le nom de la plus
belle cité des sports de l'antiquité
mais aussi l'esprit voilà de compétition
entre les peuples pour unir les peuples
autour d'eux mêmes pratiques sportives
plus que vraiment essayé de refaire les
mêmes de preuves
l'essentiel n'est pas d'avoir vaincu
mais de s'être bien battu voici les
vrais mots prononcés par pierre de
coubertin et rester dans l'histoire
comme l'important c'est de participer
tous les quatre ans à olympie le
flambeau des jeux modernes est allumé
devant le temple d'héra la flamme
olympique demeure l'un des emblèmes fort
des olympiades les jeux olympiques d'été
sont désormais l'un des événements les
plus médiatisés au monde
des milliards de téléspectateurs les
suivent en direct à la télévision
l'idéal olympique et les motivations des
organisateurs ont sans doute évolué mais
le dépassement des limites du corps
humain demeure un défi pour des
générations d'athlètes
[Musique]